thank you all for coming this is the
second panel and what we're calling
reason day here at freedom fest my name
is Anthony Randazzo I'm the director of
economic research for the reason
foundation we're going to talk about
elements of dodd-frank and problems in
regulatory climate and for financial
services on our panel today I will be
myself and also the esteem Jean Epstein
who is the economics editor at baron's I
will just keep this short and turn this
right over to Jean will try and leave
lots of conversation for Q&A next June
well first thanks thanks to Anthony and
the reason people for inviting that a
barons reporter to to speak at a recent
event my little talk is called the
dodd-frank follies I think I'm going to
be taking the high road and take the
opportunity to be what I was urging
charles murray to be yesterday and urge
others at Freedom Fest to be every once
in a while in the spirit of Milton
Friedman try to keep those radical ideas
lying around because you never know when
you might need them you know if I was
here sitting in front of you in 1987 or
1988 and told you the Berlin Wall is
going to fall in 12 months the Soviet
Union is going to unravel in a couple of
years you would have told me to go see
my shrink for my delusions of grandeur
citty those things do happen and so
let's keep those radical ideas around
let's understand what dodd-frank is all
about briefly however the wall street
reform and consumer protection act as
it's called the first question we might
ask is why no mention of Fannie and
Freddie and dodd-frank not at all Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac the two large
elephants in the room were currently
being indicted by the sec excuse me
Fannie and Freddie the joke is there not
being indicted by the SEC they've been
given a legal past because if the SEC
collected from Fannie and Freddie the
taxpayer would have to pay
so it's only the six executives have
been indicted by Fannie and Freddie and
what we have an explanation from the New
York Times from Jonas Sarah colonists
from the New York Times and Beth
macbethan mclain in their best-selling
book all the Devils are here Bethenny
rights for Vanity Fair she brings the
Social Democratic message to the to the
upper classes this is their explanation
what the reason that the legislation
makes no mention of the GSEs is that
nobody can figure out what to do can we
ever have a truly private sector market
for mortgage securitization or will it
always require government can fannie and
freddie's roles eventually grow smaller
as the financial system regains its
confidence can they be privatized the
bollox turned into government agencies
none of these answers satisfied in the
spring the Treasury Department requested
public input on the re-engineering of
the mortgage system and the reform of
the GSEs in response Treasury got more
than 570 comment letters there is no
consensus well I guess if the AG
department asked should we do away with
subsidies and rich farmers they get
about 570 comment lenders letters many
from senators from AG states and their
minions and other rich farmers and there
will be those consensus nobody knows
what to do that's the message of the New
York Times final word so to speak in
this definitive book all the Devils are
here well I'm going to skip over Judge
Posner on fannie and freddie because
actually i'm beginning to anticipate
that never run out of time he wrote a
book called a failure of capitalism my
talk on what really happened as you may
recall those of us who attended those
you attend my talk yesterday is that it
was really a failure of crap and ilysm
and that the good judge doesn't know the
difference between capitalism and
capitalism he doesn't understand profit
and loss one hopes that he'll learn that
somewhere between before the next bookie
rights which will probably be tomorrow
morning in his case well what's the
obvious explanation for what's the
no-brainer and why the the the
legislation doesn't make it and he
mentioned a Fannie and Freddie well
because it's named after Dodd and Frank
it's it's it was authored by by chris
dodd who received
five mortgages in 2003 from countrywide
financial which did extensive business
with Fannie and Freddie the Select
Committee on ethics said that dad should
have questioned why he had been put in
the Friends of Angelo VIP program
program at countrywide angelo mozilo was
head of countrywide and countrywide
eventually went it was what was
purchased because it was putting out a
lot of bad loans it was it was clearly a
minion of Fannie and Freddie and Chris
Dodd was clearly benefiting he was a
friend of Angelo of course it never
occurred to chris dodd that this was
anything unusual because i guess it was
business as usual but the embarrassment
did apparently dr chris dodd from the
Senate he's now a gather head of the
motion picture industry of America which
where presumably he can do less harm
Barney Frank Barney Frank my god he and
other house democrats sent a letter to
president george w bush in 2004 saying
the proposed crackdown would weaken
affordable housing performance by
emphasizing only safety and soundness no
the two enemies no safety and soundness
that the this of course a dog Barney
Frank but the guy is a very nimble
politician congratulations on his
marriage and we could go as you may have
read he know that's sort of nice about
him he's a politician who's willing to
be made a good husband by his his
newfound husband but apart from that he
is obviously someone that you might even
want to indict for what happened just
based on this statement you know when
you indict someone for up with respect
to financial fraud you have to approve
intent you have to prove knowledge you
know that's how they got Bernie Madoff
clearly Bernie understood what he was
doing now defected Barney I think he did
in 2003 he said about the guarantee of
Fannie and Freddie debt but there is no
guarantee there was no explicit
guarantee there was no implicit
guarantee there was no wink and not
guaranteed no guarantee of Fannie and
Freddie dead now any one would think
that anyone
understand that that clearly the market
disagreed with him the market disagreed
with him because the market by the way
many of them foreign investors some of
them central banks and I think that's
one of the reasons why Fannie and
Freddie were bailed out so quickly we're
buying Fannie and Freddie debt and
interest rates not far above the
Treasury ray Fannie and Freddie got
preferential treatment in the credit
markets so they certainly thought there
was a guarantee uneven certainly an
implicit guarantee certainly a wink and
not guarantee Barney Frank either should
not have been dealing in finance on the
hill or he was clearly intending to
Deford the taxpayer on that basis maybe
an indictment could be bought brought
against fan against Barney Frank for the
fraud because everyone was right the
market was right Fannie and Freddie as
you know I went into what is called
conservatorship in in in the summer of
2008 the the bill according to the
Congressional Budget Office is going to
be more than three hundred billion
dollars to bail that Fannie and Freddie
well we can then say obviously that the
reason why the bill does not mention
fannie and freddie is because it's named
after two of their puppets Dodd and
Frank and we perhaps I I don't even have
to go further about the dodd-frank bill
the political economy of the dodd-frank
bill is that the government and perhaps
no government can recognize that this
was not a sin of omission on the part of
the regulator this was a sin of
commission this was an explicit attempt
on the part of three presidents really
to some degree starting with george HW
bush who signed initial legislation
pushing the government into into getting
fannie and freddie and HUD and others
into high-risk mortgages starting in the
90s continued with Bill Clinton it
continued with george w bush so I bnn
boo and barney frank and chris dodd were
two big guns who are pushing it as well
so there's no question that dodd-frank
is going to do what it does which is not
at all address the problems the
created the meltdown but I want to deal
briefly with you know with with the
poster boy of dodd-frank was Paul
Volcker Obama was shown embracing Paul
Volcker when the bill was signed into
law Paul Volcker on the Volcker rule
we've been reading a lot about that
about the losses of Jamie Dimon and and
and we're supposed to think that the
Volcker Rule matters look of a banker's
going to lose a lot of money than let
them eat their losses this is a profit
and loss system there are lots of losses
that go through this system that's what
disciplines the system losses encourage
prudence losses are important to a
capitalist system but that had to do
with discretionary trading Volcker
doesn't like discretionary trading it
was his pet project but in an interview
at least mr. Volker was quick to point
out that proprietary training was not
the cause of the 2,000 crisis it was the
origination of many many bad home loans
to people who could not repay them well
if Volcker knows that then the rest of
us should whatever we mighta might not
think of proprietary trading it actually
is a kind of impossible thing to enforce
despite diamonds losses let diamond eat
those losses let him learn from those
losses that's what the capitalist system
is all about the it's important it's
really not not the kind of bill anybody
would support but more important to our
point it has nothing to do with what
dodd-frank was supposed to be about now
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
was created by dodd-frank and that's
perhaps one of the most important
outcomes of the legislation and I just
wanted to quote something a recent
bulletin from the CFPB a lot can be said
about the harm that they're doing but it
just as an indication of the fact but
this is really again the fox guarding
the chicken coop that the CFPB to the
extent that it's going to have any power
over mortgages is just basically going
to be an arm of barney frank and chris
dodd on the spirit of barney frank and
chris dodd is a recent bulletin from
them and i'd like to cook things with
relative
I want to make it clear that not giving
you a lipstick and suppressing what was
really said in response to recent
inquiries the CFPB issues this bulletin
to provide guidance about compliance
with the fair lending requirements of
the equal credit opportunity act which
makes it illegal for a creditor to
discriminate in any to credit
transaction against any applicant
because of race color religion national
art sex marital status age if the
Catholic in is old enough receipt of
income from any public assistant program
or the exercise in good faith of a right
under the consumer credit protection act
well this is continues the same
unfortunate myth that that bankers who
are presumably in the business of making
money by issuing mortgages discriminate
against black people this this opens
again opens the door completely up to
two the same kind of myth the same kind
of practice that that that financial
institutions began to hear from Janet
Reno in the 90s that they're going to be
indicted in there were cases against
banks for supposedly discriminating
against black people well here's some
data which indicates that really are the
CFPB would really want to be defending
us whites against those Asian Americans
and Native Hawaiians it shows the
percentage of applicants turned down for
conventional mortgage according to a Fed
and Civil Rights Commission study in
2000 interestingly by the way if you
look at the flip side it actually shows
that a majority of African Americans a
majority of whites and a majority of
Asian Americans and Native were actually
a few proof of mortgages so that in
itself is kind of funny but it
demonstrates obviously that White's the
discriminated that african-americans are
discriminated against in favor of whites
but those Asian Americans and Native
Hawaiians are the true one percenters of
mortgages because they get mortgages
much more readily than whites to well
clearly this is all nonsense it's clear
enough that even in two thousand there
was a tendency on the part of financial
institutions to try to look at
all of the various measures of credit
the FICO score not just the income a
whole lot of obvious things in order to
evaluate credit quality and but if see
if these CFPB is going to resurrect the
whole idea that any that this in itself
by the way would be evidence in terms of
what they stated that whites have a case
against Asian Americans and Native
Americans and that African Americans
have a case against both of them it
would be the same kind of absurdity but
that's what that's what the dodd-frank
the created Commission is going to
produce well I'm going to cut to the
chase they probably don't have to very
many more minutes let's try for the
radical solution which is which could be
lying around just in case we need it
just in case some kind of prudence
arises on Capitol Hill bring back the
banker we love to hate the SOB in charge
caller who wouldn't give you the
mortgage because your credit wasn't good
get rid of the banker we love to despise
the crap shooter who gives everyone
mortgages regarded regardless of race or
marital status he does that because he's
under the umbrella of Fannie Freddie and
the Fed because everybody had the
impression that that that Alan Greenspan
and Bernanke would provide for us all
there was absolutely no knowledge on on
the part of Eva the Federal Reserve it
as late as 2007 that a mortgage debacle
was brewing if the Fed given well its
access to data it didn't know how can
you expect anybody else to know so the
crap shooters the worst got on top as
often happens in any situation the crap
shooters have them go for the fast buck
start running our financial institutions
rather than the prudent starch bankers
would love to a so how do we bring them
back I'm in a script judge posner again
well the Obama administration points the
way the advantages of relying on private
finance to reform the housing finance
market was actually in February 2011
reforming America's housing finance
market report to Congress Congress
issued by who I don't know who wrote it
in the Obama administration but it did
mention that private actors will not be
as inclined to take on excessive risk
without the assurance of a government
guarantee behind them no longer with
taxpayers be it direct risk but
guarantee is covering most of the
mortgages well you guys really said a
mouthful congratulations to the bombing
administration they haven't acted on it
but what do we need to do well we need
to phase out all government involvement
in housing finance we need to abolish
hug joke really called by some
Department of Housing and Urban
destruction abolish Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac for further details read the
two men who have really informed me
three men in particular boolean formula
lighted Pinto Peter woloson and Alex
Palo Pinto by the way really has given
me a lot of data he was chief credit
officer a fannie mae in the late 1980s
and he's a real source of great
information how to take a government out
of Housing Finance second radical
proposal you know which wouldn't even be
necessary in this particular case
because all you all you really need to
avoid housing bubbles just to get the
government out but you need to abolish
deposit insurance in any case and
deposit insurance was opposed by one
president deposit insurance he predicted
in October 1932 would lead to laxity in
bank management and carelessness on the
part of both banker and depositor that
was Franklin Delano Roosevelt probably
the most sensible thing by far that FDR
at least of it that was ever attributed
to after you are he reluctantly signed
the glass-steagall bill that put deposit
insurance in into law at the time they
had postal savings accounts it really
went what happened with what's happened
with the deposit insurance is the
insurance limit was raised from forty
thousand two hundred thousand nineteen
eighty it's now effectively 15 million
because of seed ours because of you now
it's now effectively unlimited if you
have 15 million dollars your bank can
swap it out and create a protection at
the expense of the taxpayer I try to
tell a few social democratic friends
doesn't it bother you nature out doesn't
it bother you that fit that people with
50 million dollar accounts are being
protected by the taxpayer well we can
replace FDI insurance with Treasury
bills for people of limited means
similar to postal savings accounts
private insurance policies for the
better off or and then more importantly
those of you who care can probably check
websites which will
rhys can probably check a whole lot of
wonderful rot watchdog groups that will
arise which will tell you don't put your
money into that bank it's not managed
well put your money to the other bank
that will discipline bankers replace a
cap put capitalism in place a system of
profit and loss that encourages
risk-taking and that that also
encourages prudence thanks thanks very
much Jean a lot of intellectual
firepower there a lot of ideas that we
can we can discuss I want to build a
little bit on this idea of basically
rejecting the the status quo nature of
what dodd-frank did essentially what
dodd-frank the purported to do was to
try and solve the problems of the
financial crisis and in fact it just
built into a lot of the problems that
were in place in the first place it gave
the Federal Reserve more power and
authority it's created even more
regulatory bodies the CFPB is a all
famous now F sock the financial
stability Oversight Council or committee
which is essentially in charge of
finding financial institutions and
saying you are too big to fail and you
are too big to fail they're literally
putting labels on these on these
institutions as systemically important
financial institutions that are
identifying them as but you can go out
and you essentially do whatever you want
and we will be there to bail you out
they say that they have a resolution
system in place whether or not that is
even capable of working sorted well I
guess we'll have to see once we have the
next financial crisis we also gave
instead of letting large financial
institutions that had grown too big to
be able to manage themselves and did
make a lot of mistakes based a lot on
government regulatory incentives but
made a lot of mistakes themselves and
had a lot of ignorance instead of a line
creative destruction to take hold those
institutions have just become bigger and
so now we have institutions that are
that are even larger than before and we
even took the capital requirements
system through Basel and we've kept that
in place and we just expanded it
we kept the risk waiting nature of Basel
in in place for banks to continue to
miss allocate capital so the response of
dodd-frank and everything surrounding it
just built into the problems and that's
going to come back into the next crisis
I would take a very pessimistic tone and
say that it's not a matter of well if we
act now we can stop the next crisis
there will be another crisis we may go
through two three four more crisis
before it's possible for us to wake up
to the fact that you can't regulate
something like this a way that actually
letting real capitalism and not crony
capitalism operate is the only possible
way that we're going to have sort of
stable economic growth going forward and
what the the challenge of those of us at
Freedom Fest those of you who favor
Liberty for organizations there and for
what I see at reason is is to try and
identify as we go along how the
regulatory regime is continuing to
create problems so when peregrine
financial collapses and just as a quick
back to the back story on this so this
is a futures trading organization they
it was recently discovered that they had
a two hundred million dollar fraud on
the books the law says that if you're a
customer and you give them money that
they have to keep that money in a
separate pile from any money they invest
by themselves that's essentially a one
hundred percent reserve as opposed to
when you put money in a bank because
they had the FDIC they don't have to
keep all that money in the bank they can
go and they can lend it but if you're
with organizations like Peregrine that
they actually had to hold all of it
that's what they told the customers they
would do they broke that they broke that
that law they took 215 or so a million
of that and it's just gone it's missing
and it was because they were investing
on their own behalf and they either lost
or they spent it in some capacity now
there is a role for regulation any one
of the things that I constantly have to
when I'm speaking in the media or with
someone from a more progressive
perspective sort of push back on is we
don't want a completely unregulated
market there what is what is the role
for government to provide justice but
regulation doesn't have to come from the
government this is it does this just
because you want to monitor
organizations doesn't mean that this has
to be a government body that does this
you could have a third-party accrediting
body monitor organizations like
Peregrine that kind of like that
customers are paying that are paying
such organizations through through such
competent through and there would be
competition is to who these third-party
groups would be to provide some kind of
check to make sure that they're just not
defrauding now they can make bad bets no
one's going to stop someone from making
a bad bet but the you have to protect
property rights so when you're when
we're talking about it having a getting
peeling back layers of regulation what
we what we're talking about is getting
the government out of trying to protect
the consumers saying that there are
better ways to be monitoring protecting
consumers because the government is
incapable of doing it the CFTC is
incapable of monitoring this and for
Peregrine the CFTC which is the overall
regulator for such an organization they
went and they looked at this group last
January specifically looking for fraud
so MF Global failed last year a similar
organization they had a similar for
defrauding of their customers and so the
CFTC said oh we need to go we need to
look at a bunch of organizations they
went and they looked at this
organization Peregrine because they had
had four other major fraud violations in
the past decade so they went they looked
at their books and they said okay you're
good well this has been a two-year-long
fraud they completely missed it they are
completely more or less incompetent to
take a look at this we could run down a
very long list of failures of the SEC
there's just the it is impossible to
track every rule that is in place the
rules are too complex the skill set is
not there and to to continue to depend
on governments that regulate regulators
is not sort of a path for future growth
so we need alternative ideas then that
doesn't mean that as
hours of Liberty we just have to rail
against the idea of regulation what it
means is we need to look at what are the
best ways to to be actually monitoring
to protect property rights you don't
have to have police station at your door
to protect your own property you can
have a neighborhood watch and a lot of
people will complain that well you can't
have self regulatory bodies because the
industry will just be focused on
themselves what's all depending on how
you set up a self-regulatory body of a
self regulation body is is like a
industry association where the
incentives are aligned like peregrine
which had its own CEO on a
self-regulatory organization within the
futures industry there was all made up
of people in the industry their
incentives were to protect their own
their incentives were to protect
institutions their incentives were not
to protect their customers so if you're
going to set up a self-regulatory
organization it has to have the proper
properly align incentives so when we're
thinking about problems of dodd-frank
and we're trying to point things out
that are in the market I think that
there are ways that we can highlight
that this is not the right response
which is building into more problems
there are solutions and it doesn't have
to be a chaotic anarchist system
hopefully hopefully arguments like that
or something that can maybe we can just
sort of keep around to win eventually
and maybe it's optimistic to say they'll
be five practices from now maybe it'll
be 50 crisis is from now but that we can
sort of keep around to when there might
be some moment of waking up to push us
more towards measures of Liberty in
financial sector
you